[Music]
in jailed rapper news submitted by
shotsfired Swedish prison detaining ASAP
rocky fires back at claims he's being
captain inhumane conditions not sveden
he's still in jail yeah how long was he
in show he was in jail I don't know
either until I read this so he's been
there for two weeks
oh that's a long yeah they can only hold
him for two weeks for what so what
happened was that there was these two
guys on the streets of Stockholm
harassing ASAP and his crew and they
just kept like just gonna leave him
alone like he they kept following yeah
they know who he was probably right it's
not clear the [ __ ] aren't running
uh-huh they try running well they just
kept I'm like dude leave us alone
there's a video but I'm not gonna bother
showing you as well like was following
fight two blocks then I would just start
going faster but not if you're just like
in the middle of the day and the
innocent lose them you shouldn't have to
run yeah exactly just like me alone so
that your abs if you want to get get
some distance between you guys exactly
so then a sub says or like he you could
see in the video that he was just very
calm and saying like hey man like we're
not trying to go to jail like just leave
us alone like trying to defuse a
situation but these guys just kept
persisting a big Swedish guys I'm not
sure but why would he have a good
Swedish guys I don't I'd say I bet it
was Americans oh no they were I saw the
video they were drunk so you couldn't
tell but they also had an accent yeah
and they were like it sounded Indian but
I'm not sure yeah yeah so then um well
it's a ended up posting that those
videos that someone in his team recorded
and said like these druggies like drug
addicts like kept harassing those kind
of thing which led to him being arrested
and being held or being you know
detained in a Swedish jail and they're
saying that they're detaining him
because he was on a world tour so they
didn't want him leaving like fleeing the
country so that's why they detained him
but detained him for what because of the
fact that there was a street fight or
like they're trying to like the guy that
they got into a fight yeah
I think they were looking for more
something and then he turned himself in
yeah he ended up turning himself in to
the police
yeah that's why and they arrested him
yeah well if we turn to MIT himself and
he's not hopefully oh the video that's
out right now doesn't show the whole
thing so there probably could have been
other things that we it's just not out
there yet but it was pretty clear in the
video that the bodyguard was just trying
to shoo him away like like bugs like get
away you know yeah I didn't they kept
harassing him and you know at the end of
the video the lady's like hey did those
guys mess with you - yeah they slapped
my friend and like did this and they
were just yeah they were causing some
problems and one something they went to
Ikea jail we had to build their own so
that to build it with the allen wrench
yep for everything whatever nothing
there are federally lingonberry juice i
think i kids from Sweden right Oh fine I
got the job yeah it was a great love
this have you ever been I sometimes I'll
go there just get the meatballs yeah I
go there just for the food I don't even
like the first guy's dollar ice cream I
just okay okay so it's a rockies manager
he has launched an online petition
claiming that the prison that he's
staying in they have the rapper under
24/7 solitary confinement restriction of
amenities for the most basic of human
functions to palatable and
life-sustaining food as well as
unsanitary conditions oh my god
apparently they're saying that for the
first five days he only ate an apple a
day because the food was not edible if
the place is not clean the waters not
clean he's been sleeping on a yoga mat
with no blanket there's a prisoner in
the next cell that has severe mental
issues and he's slamming his head
against the concrete and hurls feces
everywhere and it's so they're saying
that this is this place that where he's
being held right I was just like not fit
for human beings my god and why are they
treating him like he committed murder
right yeah I don't know the crazy thing
is like Sweden has a reputation for
having like really good like their jails
is better than our like apartments
they're voted the happiest country in
the world
who voted on this everyone the world you
know but they have this pretty crazy
reputation and all kinds of like they do
documentaries about their jail system
and how their what do you call it the
they actually rehabilitate criminals
into the society yes they have released
this prisoners like released photos and
said like you know this is the place
that he's staying in which I'll show you
in a second and then they also really
release the menu that they give the
prisoners you're the person themselves
released this no no yeah the prison like
they can order I'll take the tater tots
why are they keeping him confined to
solitary confinement it's an ongoing
case they can't release too many details
no wonder yeah so what's happening here
is that they're they're trying to like
defend themselves as the prison that's
why they're doing it so let me show you
some photos here's a snap I just picture
a make it and then they wake up them up
with like a pail of cold water yeah just
so handsome dude with some dope fashion
oh this is the petition is there's this
hashtag now called hashtag justice for
Rocky and this is the prison he's being
Instagram photo yeah so these are the
photos that they're release that [ __ ]
looks better than some of our dorm rooms
prisons really saying that's that yoga
mat yeah there's the yoga is that him in
his room I don't think it but it looks
like they [ __ ] put everything in its
place today you got the good lighting
they open up the shiny orange there's
their feet yeah covered shoes they clean
the floors for that picture Jesus Christ
yeah yeah so another scandalous thing
about this whole thing is the fact that
ASAP was trying to get representation
and they were like denying it which is
it oh yeah there's a treaty called the
Vienna Convention for consular relations
say that five times faster no and then
so that treaty is between Sweden and the
United States and under that treaty it
says that when a foreigner is arrested
he has the right to immediately see an
official from the US consulate yeah
they're saying that rocky did ask for
that meeting but when the official from
the American consulate arrived to meet
him he was denied access which is a
violation of the treaty they violated
the Vienna Convention yeah you never
heard of that we need to go to war now
yeah that's that's a movie [ __ ] so happy
they're supposed to be so [ __ ]
welcome dude there that this hypocrisy
is crazy they did eventually allow it
constantly official to see him two days
later no but it was only in the
President and year shot of two Swedish
guards which they're saying that it was
a clear intimidation tactic oh my god
would they like seven feet tall
like Hello [ __ ] four hundred pounds
very European bald yeah and so also
they're saying that when the official
went to go visit him that he was saying
that the it was walking into that place
was like walking into a toilet
whoa yeah and then he does often it
smells like [ __ ] he does often and then
the embassy officials said that they
have visited several prisoners at that
facility of it over the past year and a
lot of them lost is shocking amount of
weight mmm
people aren't even eating at this place
because the food so like disgusting you
know what the conspiracy is mucho I
think the guards are eating the food
that's all they're so big no sound at
all I didn't know nothing's edible cuz
like they only give him an apple it's
pretty crazy though that he's still in
jail so mute and also they're trying to
keep him until mid-august dish like
they're trying to prolong his trial and
the crazy thing is we don't even know
what he's in there for know normally in
Sweden you can only keep people for two
days and so they were why yes how do you
know that cuz I read about this article
oh I thought you read about the Vienna
Convention of course no so then then
they requested to keep him for two weeks
and so and then so now they're talking
about mid August that's [ __ ] not yeah
what was he doing in Sweden anyway I
won't World Tour okay they were about to
[ __ ] perform at the Ikea Center but
yeah so now they're all
artists like Tyler the Creator and
Schoolboy Q they have said they will not
be doing any more tours I joined this
fight
JK will not tour GK will not tour at
Sweden until ASAP Rocky's release or
anywhere else to the country they got
this system can you see they got like
those Universal core things I think but
you can sue if you can't take a jail to
court that's [ __ ] up because then they
can do anything I mean look what's
happening at the border right now like
that's [ __ ] up they're gonna be
they're gonna hold this trial at the UN
court the United Nations the Vienna
Convention VVC is a sponsored by the
sausages - yeah obvi Vienna sausages and
he must be going [ __ ] crazy in there
what would you do for two weeks and
you're isolated confinement yeah I've
met it eight the position of that right
now
yes well my fingers are why well you're
not gonna pitch black this picture the
boy'll an American consultant a soldier
come on it's completely dark and you
only get one hour of sunlight that's the
law so 23 3 23 hours of pitch darkness
what kind of [ __ ] what because like
you don't go there
unless you like you you're in jail and
then you try to kill someone else and
someone else and someone else will okay
we need to put this guy away like a
danger it's still crazy man it should
not be allowed out but it's the best the
way it is and it's Sweden like we don't
know what the rules are how they are
different because clearly he didn't
murder someone in jail and you murder
someone on the street yeah he's in
that's crazy to me maybe you know what
that should think pools sometimes it's
like he's famous so we're worried about
his safety so we're putting him in
solitary confinement so the people in
jail don't hurt him
what about so like let's say you're
traveling you're a stop rocky and then
you have your dog in a dog hotel and you
don't go pick up her dog weapons her dog
then it dies you think they're gonna
care about his dogs absolutely
I wonder yeah I wonder if his whole team
went to jail I know cuz there were other
people involved in this whole situation
I wonder if he's cool with the Swedish
mafia because they're musicians and it
each other be like yo help me out
Swedish mafia if not like a house yeah
don't they like battle back and forth
with their songs that's the whole thing
hey [ __ ] DJ yeah that's how they
perform as a DJ I've been there's very
lovely there oh we didn't know guys
where did you go oh well I don't even
know their capital what were you guys
doing there maybe your [ __ ] business
yeah I'm not answer anything you we have
Swedish we have Swedish fans that watch
nice yeah hi can you tell us what the
[ __ ] is going on over there in the
comments below yes please explain to us
what's going on I'm [ __ ] picket
fences especially because like you said
I thought Sweden was like hyper woke it
would be there so fair and nice and all
that yeah I wonder why I like what maybe
ASAP did something really bad we just
don't know about it like why do they
keep my stuff like that they are keeping
the prison like that like IKEA looking
people
nope no because remember the the guy
said that walking in there was I'm
walking to the toilet and that other
people had lost a lot of weight like
there are not answer maybe it's like
it's like what Singapore
we're like if you [ __ ] scream that
this wasn't like trending on Twitter
like I didn't hear about this until all
the other rappers are posting about it
oh yeah they don't follow my rappers do
you know the way they talk to each other
in jail is through the toilets what do
you know that's in prison don't worry
about it I'm gonna [ __ ] piss alright
alright you can talk to them through the
toilet okay pipes yeah through the pipes
and you can send things any slushy and
when the water goes out they go a little
bit a bit bigger than that the one you
can send like what do they type they die
together
no no no you have to you have to like
build a thing that'll catch their string
and then they send think that's how many
pest drugs in jail they call it the
toilet fortune well you exposes some
things lots enough okay welcome so
anyone who goes to jail needs to do
drugs
[Music]